In the last lecture we talked about monadic
image processing, and that is where we take
a pixel from the input image, apply a function
to it and put the result into the corresponding
pixel in the output image.
And we looked at a number of functions: we
looked at gamma encoding and decoding; we
looked at thresholding; and so on.
So the same function is applied to every single
pixel in the image.
What happens here is that every output pixel
is a function of the pixels in a square region
around the corresponding point in the input
image.
So the input to the function is a number of
pixels, the output is a single pixel value.
Such a function, which is based on a number
of pixels, can then say something either about
the uniformity or the variation of the pixels
over that input square region.
We call this a window and denote it by the
symbol W.
So let’s consider an example function we
might use and a common one would be to consider
the average.
So what we are going to do is for that square
input window, take all of the pixel values,
compute the average, and place the average
into the corresponding pixel in the output
image.
So here is the original image, the Mona Lisa
image that we have seen before.
And the output is the average pixel value
over a 7 by 7 window.
So what the average can do is it can reduce
noise but we also see that it reduces the
resolution—it has made this image look somewhat
blurry.
Let’s see how this actually works in practice;
and I have constructed a toy example here
where we have an input grey scale image double
precision input image.
So the pixel values vary between 0 and 1.
So we have a grey background with values of
0.3 and a bright square in the middle where
the pixel values are 0.8.
We will start the animation and what we can
see here is the input pixel window, which
is shown here as red and it is moving, marching
across the image left to right, top to bottom.
And what you can see on the right-hand side
are the average values being deposited into
the output image.
Couple of things to note: first of all, note
that we can’t compute the pixel values in
the outer most row and column pixels.
And we will talk about that shortly.
Also note that the quite clearly obvious bright
white square in the input image has been smeared
out.
That value of 0.8 only exists now at a single
pixel in the output image.
Around that are some slightly brighter values
and beyond that is the background and so we
see here what we saw when we took the average
of the Mona Lisa image—that the sharp, crisp,
boundaries in the image have been smeared
out or blurred.
Now the effect of the window size makes a
real difference.
So again, here is our input image and if we
compute the average with a 7 by 7 window moving
over the input image, this is the result,
and if we increase the size of the window,
now it is a 21 by 21 window.
We can see that it is very blurry indeed.
So what tends to happen is that any feature
in the image that is smaller than the size
of the window will be very strongly attenuated.
It will tend to disappear in the output image.
We might say that the output image is blurry,
fuzzy, has a lower resolution or whatever.
We have blurred out, smoothed over fine detail
in the image.
Let’s try this in a full scale image.
We are going to load our favourite image the
Mona Lisa into the workspace variable im.
I am going to compute a new image with the
workspace variable I am going to call s7.
And every output pixel is the average of a
7 by 7 neighbourhood or window of the pixels
in the input image.
To do that I am going to use the tool box
function icon and will explain about this
function a bit more as we proceed.
The first argument is the image that I am
going to perform the average on which is the
Mona Lisa image in the workspace variable
im.
The second argument defines the area over
which we compute the average.
Now I wanted to compute the average over a
7 by 7 window and so to specify that, I pass
in a matrix with a function ones(7,7).
That produces a matrix that is 7 by 7 and
every element in that matrix
is 1.
So that second argument defines the region
over which I am going to perform the average
for every single input pixel.
I am going to display the original Mona Lisa
image.
And I am going to create another figure.
I am going to display the averaged version
of that and we can see that there is a lot
less detail in the background.
It is much smoother; you might say it is blurrier,
you might say it has got lower resolution.
Now let’s increase the size of the region
over which we are doing the averaging.
So I am going now to correlate with a window
which is 21 by 21 pixels in size.
Now I am going to display that image and we
can see that this looks very blurry indeed.
The effect of averaging over a region of pixels
is to eliminate very fine detail within the
image, so any detail that is of a size that
is smaller than the window that we are using,
in this last case, 21 by 21 pixels, any detail
that is the order of 1 or 2 pixels in size
is going to be eliminated.